hello
okay so i was just reminiscing with a
friend of mine about how when we were
chatting at the emmys
it was like
your crew was the biggest partiers the
entire time celebrating it was almost
like every time we came back to you i
was like hey so about this award and you
just we're all getting drunker and
drunker and drunker
which i love and we all love so the
question for me is like when does that
start does that start now with the
nominations because you're nominated
alongside to your co-stars so are you
you know
oh i don't
i tell you well that's a given
with us
i mean we're already socializing for one
of our birthdays last week anyway and it
was messy and
very late slash early lovely um
secondly
my girls juno temple and sarah niles
come on a girl
honestly i i got very emotional when i
found out about her particularly and
taheed james and james lance and dame
harriet walter because
they are the best at what they do they
bring an
ridiculous amount to this show the one
those of them that are newer in the
shape of sarah my god she came in
like an elegant elegant swan to the
point where even in the first
read-through juno and i were like
she's really good and makes us feel like
we're 12. she's perfectly cast because
she brings that still
economic energy to the proceedings so
for her to be recognized i was
absolutely thrilled and they are all the
best eggs in the box that's so wonderful
you know as amazing as it would be
to have a back to back for you which
would be a phenomenal celebration
well get out of here
i don't
see that because there are crazy crazy
crazy people in this category i mean
particularly ridiculous talent in this
category
so
i'm gonna go along i'm going to have a
lovely time and i'm going to fangirl
them out of whoever wins because i love
them all genuinely
so when you got the news what were you
in the middle of what were you doing i
was having an iced coffee by myself in a
coffee shop were you waiting like
because it's the day
no you just were hanging out yes because
um i had things to do i was busy in the
middle of my day and because we have the
time difference i hadn't actually
registered
what time it was
and because i
didn't expect
a second year's acknowledgement
i was a bit like
when my manager rang i literally went
hey darling
and then he went
so
considering
magical there certainly wasn't any like
refresh right right right well that's a
lovelier way to get it just to be there
doing your thing you're considering the
the um
wealth of nominations that you and the
crew
got
is do you get together on like
a facetime or zoom call or something
like who's calling who first to
congratulate them
well i actually
cut my
phone call short with my manager today
because i was like i've got to ring to
him
so i faced time to heave and we both
just grinned and didn't speak
and and then i went i told you and he
was like
you did and i was like i told you that
you i was going to prove you wrong he
was like no no no that's not going to
happen i was like yeah i will but anyway
and i said who would have known if
somebody told us when we were lying in
that bed together shooting our scenes
that we would both be nominated for this
season
honestly and then i i don't mind saying
i got very emotional talking to him
because i'm extremely proud of what he's
achieved and what this will bring his
way
this show and i know it's been said a
hundred times and i i'll say it again
especially in the years that we've all
gone through together this has been like
the thing that people have been using as
like
as a comfort
to keep them happy to connect them to
their friends and now that we're going
to be getting the third and final season
i know people who are already kind of
mourning the fact that they're not going
to have
more of the show after that but what
does it mean for you because you're such
a close-knit group
like you work together you pray together
you support each other yeah
i have to say
of anyone who is mourning i am already
mauling the loss of it as
a job of it as a group of friends who
jailed from day one there is less than
no competition
i mean seriously
and
to
say goodbye to rebecca welton for me
is odd
really odd i take it very seriously
maybe sometimes more seriously than i
should
about serving someone who's fictional
but she doesn't feel fictional to me
how how will she rank for you you know
down the line when you're looking back
on all the work that you've done
how will this character rank for you and
100 number one yeah
yeah because there have been so many
parallels in hers and my life to the
point where i used to tease jason and go
have you literally got cameras in my
house
i mean ridiculous even down to
this season that we're nominated for now
um i was just saying to somebody not
many people know that my own father was
having emergency quintuple bypass
surgery on the day i was shooting that
eulogy standing in front of rebecca's
dad's coffin
and i had said goodbye to my dad that
morning and i didn't know if i was ever
going to see him again
the parallels
are literally ridiculous
and
there have been ways where
she has helped me
cope with what has happened in my life
in previous relationships and things
and i have served her by knowing how to
play her
amazing and for the fans that are
excited for season three like what what
are the words that you would use
to describe
what we're gonna go through watching it
um
joy
sorrow joy
reprint joy sorrow joy in that order
yeah
okay
okay we're looking forward to it anna
congratulations thank you so much and
thank you so much for taking the time